so how come we pizza the way we do you
know as well as I do if I just hold it
like this it flops over and you know as
well as I do that if I curl like this I
can eat so why do we pizza like this
Gauss Gauss tells us wife once cows have
to do it
cows came up with this absolutely nifty
theorem called the theremin grigio also
in English called the remarkable theory
curvature is an intrinsic property of
surfaces curvature we all kind of know
what a curve is what's curvature this
piece of paper has no curvature at all
right flat going this way flat going
this way we'll come back to that what
about a sphere well a sphere clearly has
curvature going outward this way in out
we're going curvature this way if both
curves are outward gauss says oh
multiply them together this is a
positive this is a positive positive I'm
positive means oh it's a positive
curvature so this is positive curvature
right here everywhere on a sphere it's
positive curvature what about a banana
for banana
I see along here along here it's curving
out along this way it's curving out so
this is positive curvature but watch
this watch this over here
oh it's curving outward along here we
remember that but along here it's
curving inward so this is this one is a
negative Gaussian curvature this one is
a positive a positive times a negative
means that at this point I have a
negative curvature so someplace along
line here and along the line here the
curvature of a banana changes from being
positive Gaussian curvature to negative
Gaussian curvature for a torus along
here it's curving outward that's cool
along this way it's curving outward
outward times outward is positive so
that's positive
but over on the inside over here it's
curving outward there but inward here so
this means this is negative curvature so
it's negative curvature around here
positive curvature so someplace around
this line in a torus and along someplace
around here it goes from negative
Gaussian curvature to positive that
makes sense to me what gauss said and
his remarkable theorem this curvature is
intrinsic to the surface so if I have
something that starts out with a certain
integrated dowsing total curvature then
no matter how I stretch it and turn it
around and move it it's going to stay
the same I know that this piece of paper
starts out flat if I bend it I'll draw a
line here you I'll bend it sort of along
that line okay well they're in this
direction there's negative curvature but
along here so there's - going along
there but this has still zero curvature
so it's a straight line it's a straight
line going that way but going this way
it's negative curvature flipping on the
other side look over here I still have
no curvature in that line and I have
positive curvature over here well what's
the Gaussian curvature right at this
point right here it's some positive
number times zero ah Gauss tells us that
Gaussian curvature
the multiplication of this direction
curvature and this direction curvature
is intrinsic to the surface that means
that if I bend it this way and I get
positive curvature at this point since
the surface started out with no
curvature flat no curvature at all that
if I add positive curvature here I'd
better
multiply that by something that has zero
curvature which is a straight line so I
if I have curvature in this direction
I'd better have no curvature there what
about a pizza come here breathe here
come come come if I have a flat pizza
and I lift it up like this it's going to
bend down if it bends this way then oh
there's Gaussian curvature is positive
here put it with a zero going this way
but I can take advantage of that by
saying I will make this have no
curvature along here a negative Gaussian
curve negative curvature there so at
each of these points curvature stays the
same
if it tries to flop this way while I'm
curving it this way the pizza would be
violating Gauss's remarkable theorem
pizzas don't like to do that
we'd like to thank the great courses
plus for supporting this episode now
this is a collection bursting with over
7,000 different video lessons and
courses that you can stream on to your
computer your laptop your phone your
tablet all the usual devices these
videos are good fun but they're also
really in-depth and they cover all sorts
of subjects from literature history I've
been watching some about chess lately
and of course they've got plenty about
mathematics there are loads of examples
I could give just one that I think is
really good is all about the mathematics
of games and puzzles this is a whole
bunch of videos and lessons covering all
sorts of things from casino games
blackjack Sudokus you name it and really
going into depth about the mathematics
underlying these games I think number
files will really love it no tests no
homework just really interesting lessons
from these world-class professors now
the great courses plus is offering you a
free one-month trial of their service
access to all these videos free of
charge and if it seems like your thing
you can continue from as low as $14.99
on the screen there's also a link in the
description you can click on the great
courses plus.com slash numberphile free
one-month trial make sure you use the
links so they know you came from this
episode and our thanks to them for
supporting us in other words the reason
why there's a correct way to eat pizza
and this won't flop over is that if it
flopped over like this I would be
forcing a point right here to change its
Gaussian curvature not just an intrinsic
part of a piece of paper but an
intrinsic part of a piece of pizza